there can i press your button now can
you just remind me
that article that sentence of the
article that
compared you to the jazz music
so there was a there was a when i was
trying to
to figure myself out and to find my
voice as an artist
and to position myself in the world and
to figure out
where i stand and how to stand and how i
wanted to stand when i was thinking
about
how to show up i envisioned myself in
the third person
and i saw myself as someone who
was a lot more courageous and expressive
than who i thought i was when i was
brooding in anxiousness and
self-consciousness and so
i envisioned myself in the third person
as a person
free of self-consciousness somebody who
could be truthful somebody who could be
transparent
somebody who could tell the truth and
then i wanted
to to uh engender
the con because we are contextual beings
right
so i knew that who i was at home with my
parents or who i was when i was
sitting with cool kids in school wasn't
the person i wanted to be when i was at
my most
truthful and so i envisioned myself
becoming the version of me that was the
most truthful
right i wanted i wanted who i was to
shine brightly
free of inhibition or constrain and so
in order to do that
i engendered spaces where i could uh
lose myself
surrender myself let everything go and
do a
basically perform a trustful for myself
right
like this is like open-heart surgery of
the psyche like i wanted to express
myself completely and without inhibition
and then i wanted to document that
i wanted to capture that lightning in a
bottle what happens
when i become the person that's there
when i'm not there and and the person
that's there when i'm not there like who
i am when i'm
broken open can that be captured you
know is it possible
for those transcriptions to be recorded
without self-consciousness
collapsing the the through line right
the minute you become aware of yourself
your
your train of thought gets garbled and
then and then and then you ruin the take
you ruin the moment you're no longer
being truthful but anyway i was able to
engender this i was able to create the
conditions in which i could witness
myself getting out of myself i was in a
state of ecstasy i was beside myself and
then
what happened is something came through
comes through you but not from you and
though it is with you it belongs not to
you
and then watching the recording later
and setting it to music
took my breath away and then i tried to
explain to people what is this i'm like
well
i'm trying to show you my inner life
when i'm having an epiphany
right i'm trying to capture an epiphany
in real time genuine inspiration
an eruptive an eruption from a volcano
and i shared my work with people and i
was just starting out and trying to get
myself noticed and eventually
it caught the attention of i believe the
imaginary foundation my friend nick
phillip who then wrote a review about my
work they normally make t-shirts and
what he said
was that i was like a modern-day charlie
mingus um and that i
modern-day charlie mingus
who uh
who who riffs and rhapsodizes through a
tumbling
thicket of ideas with such a sharp and
vital alacrity that it takes the breath
away
i i can see why you liked it
it's just so it's like a colorful
necklace you know those
sounds like a color it was like the most
beautiful thing
i couldn't believe that guy was talking
about my work i felt for a moment
complete
like a modern day charlie mingus he
riffs and rhapsodizes
through a thumb through a tumbling okay
let's start again
like a modern day charlie mingus he
riffs and rhapsodizes through a tumbling
thicket of ideas with
such a sharp and vital alacrity that it
can take the breath away
and i was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] who's
he talking about but the guy was
describing if you ever
work if you ever write a book or
something that's like you know
behind the books like there's these
references of like
impressive yeah yeah like telegraphs or
i mean like uh like uh journal uh a
journal uh
establishment or a person yes they live
like
the sentence that describes the entire
message of the book so that's that
should be put as
the main title behind your book oh well
yeah description i mean
not only not only did it nail down my
the deepest aspirations for freedom for
himself
was to basically become jazz stop trying
to make art and just become art
and that description to me seemed like
an account of somebody who had become
jazz
you know to riff and rhapsodize through
a tumbling thicket of ideas with such a
sharp and vital alacrity that it can
take the breath away
is beyond measure
you know i wish i knew that guy i wish i
was that guy
you know i think you you can you can
become this
if for a moment and then you relapse
back into yourself
you know a being that shits and dies and
gets moody and depressed and anxious and
all that jazz
but i have touched the promised land you
know and
anyway um well i just want to say yeah
for example
me too that's why i love you i love
listening you riff
i love uh i love listening to terence
mckenna
i love listening to jamie wheel i just
love
listening to beautiful language that uh
just uh just explains
explains away things in understandable
matter
percent 100 i i like i get turned on by
that no no i know
no no that's called don't worry it's
called cognitive ecstasy
yeah people who are bewitched by
language
are cognitive ecstasy addicts and i
think
ultimately what the the lightning in a
bottle that i want to capture
is cognitive ecstasy i want my videos
to evoke cognitive ecstasy i want my
videos to be
state changing technologies
right i want to overwhelm not just an
audience but myself
into an altered state i want to induce
reveries
so that i can riff and rhapsodize
through a tumbling thicket of ideas with
such a sharp and vital alacrity that it
can take the breath away like i want to
play
jazz i want to become jazz and i want to
jazz
the audience that listens to my work i
mean that's the goal i think of
of any artist we are bewitched by
language we are bewitched by art we have
become
our art in our in our
most precious and breathless moments
you